bad boys bad boys what you gonna do what
you're gonna do and Will Smith and
Martin Lawrence come back for you 20 21
yeah have you seen bad boys yeah it's
been a long time but uh bad boys too
yeah yeah you seen bad boys - you ain't
seen Bob yeah yeah I'm ready I'm ready
for Burnett and Lowry to come back and
do some more you know drug busting and
you know whoa whoa whoa
don't say drug look at yell dollar bills
oh that's right you know play the bad
boys theme song in this trailer you know
what don't demon attacks let's just
describe the trailer because it's
probably gonna be tuned let's just watch
this what are we doing
[Music]
the guys directors who were like we
wonder if this exactly no you can get
that right now I got this I'm gonna
penetrate this man so with my heart
[Music]
always says that yes
Easter's remember charity work with me
I'm asking you man that boy's life
was he go to the hospital
Wow cool stuntmen
that's like crazy in that yeah a lot of
it looks in camera yeah yeah I feel like
that's powerful little probably my
favorite thing about this trailer is
that the action does look very merry
bone-crunching and very visceral and
very yeah in camera yeah I mean you know
I don't have a lot of expectation for
bad boys what do I want - chemistry -
will and Martin and while there to be
some cool action wanton destruction you
want you know yes rug busts and babes
and stuff and I mean to me like bad boys
1 & 2 or some of Michael Bay's best
directing movies he is not returning for
this but it looks like they got these
two directors who clearly love the bad
boys franchise because they directed
this almost exactly all the shock look
exactly like out of a Michael baby yeah
yeah I wish I actually did appreciate
the way this trailer starts off with
like a classic base shot that then gets
completely disrupted by you know not an
amazing joke but a joke well that's rig
it's like a bad boys joke don't you know
Will Smith has nice cars yeah mike has
I'm sorry I'm a I'm a bad boy bad boy my
bad my - have to investigate your
behavior I'm sorry this is a great porno
the thing is like this is I feel like
what every action franchise gets to rub
up against at some point is you either
die the hero or you live long enough to
see yourself do a sequel where you're
making a bunch of old joke yeah where
it's like all Martin Lawrence has got
the glasses now cuz he's old he can't
see in stuff I mean all these kinds of
jokes are the exact same kinda jokes
there were in the last bad boys maybe
except Martin Lawrence
is definitely showing a lot mornings a
little bit chubbier in the cheeks
you know Will Smith looks like a mazy
still yeah I should keep doing this and
then maybe Martin Lawrence I mean I was
I'm just glad they brought Joe
Pantoliano back is the captain he's the
the highlight of all these movies really
well you know you have scenes in the
movies he really steals the show you
know even there's like a lot of shots
that really feel like Michael Bay at the
same time I'm I kind of get the
impression that some of the more
dialogue driven scenes will be a little
less scattershot a little bit more
competent in its direction like I like
bad boys two times I think it's a little
hyper hyper edited even in it's just you
know dialogue scenes but I still think
it's a really funny movie
and I guess I guess honestly I would
have I was excited at the thought of
different people helming this because I
wanted to see what they could bring
that's different to it and me and I'm
sure when I watched the movie I'll be
able to see some of that I just right
now in this trailer it does just seem
like you know well this is the weird
moment where I'm sitting here going you
know it's weird not having Michael Bay
because like he is I mean they've got
obviously his style is too earmarks and
I'm sure by now everyone's had enough
time to study what makes a Michael Bay
film what it is but but being that bad
boys is of all the franchise's Michael
Bay has involved with for some reason
bad boys to me always seems like the
Michael Bay of them and there's so it
does seem like something is kind of
missing not having him and I don't know
really what that is because you know
Michael Bay has very distinct sense of
humor a very distinct sensibility and I
don't yeah it doesn't look like that's
missing and I just wonder what the
overall impact of his lack of presence
would be on the movie yeah you know I
just sometimes I just get the impression
and the reason I keep bring
it up is often times when there's a
specific director attached to a
franchise and then another director
comes in to fill the shoes and they
don't just you know follow their own
sensibilities or just go with their own
style but they try to emulate the prior
director style usually they're just
naturally feels like there's something
missing yeah so it might seem like a
minor concern because it's it's just
seem like what's the big deal but you
know those movies have like a lot of
energy and I have a lot of flair editing
style to it by the good the great thing
is is that it has been essence oh
definitely that's who's gonna save this
whole thing now move over Gabrielle
Union everyone I have encima rarely see
Martin Lawrence anywhere anymore
and also dude you're missing out Will
Smith it was like I won't do men in
black 4 but I'll gladly do a bad boys 3
but Zoe it's cool that he gets to have
another trilogy you know yeah that's
what we really need is more Will Smith
trilogies come on man it's I've been
wanting this for a long time people have
been wanting this it is it is cool to
watch this at least get to come what
hopefully is full circle or something
yeah get that nice three crisp number in
there well Martin Lawrence looks like
he's he's not gonna retire again bad
boys 4 comes out you know then they can
be geriatric man think of a bad man but
that doesn't matter how much of a gap
there is between these fees it's the
same setup with these characters every
every episode the world resets they're
on a new bust and when Lawrence is too
old for this [__]
yeah and Will Smith hot shot yeah you
know and he's making out with a
different champ it's gonna cause trouble
in the plot I'm cool with that I'm cool
with that this looks like a lot of fun
and I'll definitely be there and this
could this looks like on its verge Anne
you airy movie that you know sometimes
we get great horror film sometimes we
get a really funny comedies this looks
like oh the most exciting action movie
to come out in January ever you know
I was really hoping nails that doesn't
turn out to be like because the things
bad boys movies are also long and I last
one yeah especially as I don't love
necessarily Michael Bay I do have a
weird trust in him for like helming way
too long of an action movie where is
like for any other director of mine I
don't know yes and now all we need is
you know rush hour for Wow while Wes -
well you know these guys are doing the
next 48 hours as of now yeah yeah that's
their next I heard that are also doing
Beverly Hills or Beverly is hot that's
what they were doing yeah I never mind
sorry about 40 hours you know another
and on all Eddie Murphy movies are the
same area alright guys well are you
excited for bad boys for life this does
look like a lot of fun you guys can
leave your comments down below what are
you most looking forward to you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell go ahead and check us
out on patreon where we do weekly Q&A
Stevie show reactions stream along sync
up with us or some of those shows have
options for reaction highlights included
footage so you're not gonna worry about
doing that thank you guys for being here
much love